hello I'm Nick Offerman and welcome to
woods support at mark plays games asks
please help settle an argument our what
working aprons really necessary
hashtag woodworking yes they are any
protective garment is is necessary it
may it depends on what you're doing but
we wear aprons because they protect our
civilian clothing from finishing
products and just dust in general and
they have handy pockets in which you can
store things like pencils rulers and
your one header at Evan e Richards asks
if I'm staining a big piece of red oak
do I need to use a pre-stain conditioner
or will oak take the stain well as it is
don't ever stain the red oak if you're
gonna stain it get something cheaper
than red oak use poplar
I hate stain and Beast thing asks what
books would you recommend for someone
who wants to learn about woodworking
there's a lot of really good books
there's one that I happen to write
called good clean fun that's great for
beginners woodworking in general has a
lot of different specializations but the
ones that I would generally recommend
would be anything by George Nakashima a
fellow named TAFE read ta GE Fri D at
mod Jam five one five asks good sir
wrapping up my first wood project to
house guitar amp added second and final
coat of poly do ice and again after dry
it depends on how good of a brush worker
you are if you get a perfectly smooth
finish then you don't need to sand it
again personally I don't like the glossy
shine that comes from most finishes so
after the final coat I will at least
scuff it with a for aught for zero steel
wool or a super fine steel wool just to
knock down the shine it all depends on
how nice your finishes ass
the Jimmy Chicago asks what's your
favorite shape of dovetail that's an
ignorant question because there's only
one shape of dovetail it is the dovetail
shape
but if you're asking maybe what's my
favorite size of dovetail I do like tiny
pins in a dovetail layout I think that's
handsome and it belies a mastery of the
form at ATAR underscore s asks need
advice on oil / varnish that helps
maintain the look and feel of antique
table over a hundred year old but isn't
prone to watermarking there's a great
set of books by a fellow named Bob
Flexner on finishing that would be a
much better resource than me I dislike
any finish but some sort of oil varnish
mix that's applied by hand I would
basically just up up your varnish in
your proportion so that it has a higher
protection but if you can create a
sample board and experiment with
different mixes and then hold them up to
the existing finish to see which one
looks the most right and use coasters
woodworking guys asks new question what
angle should I cut a miter joint at I
would first address your grammar
next time try at what angle should I cut
a miter joint traditionally you're going
for a 90-degree corner so you always
bisect your angle so that would be a
45-degree angle all your corners should
add up to 360 degrees so if you're
making a picture frame that's four times
ninety degrees that's 360 for making a
hexagon that's six corners that means 60
degrees per corner bisected would be 30
degrees but generally a miter joint
refers to 45 degrees at grant Rothberg
asks true or false most adorable
woodworking assistant ever
looks like a clean diaper she's
preferring a two by two of some soft
wood I'm guessing pine which loses a
couple of adorability points but pretty
cute and one might ask is that apron
necessary
I'll give her a seven pretty cute also I
can't really approve her Footwear but
she is cute at photo dude 24 asks master
crafter of wood period I assume you're
referring to me I'm a student of the
forum but I appreciate your optimism I
beseech thee what kind of joint is this
it blows my mind
funky form and function in an antique
I've seen this joinery in in some
antique drawers and it's very
cool-looking and probably pretty
effective but I don't think it's that
impressive because it's pretty clearly
made by a machine you can imagine a
sequence of Forstner bits that have a
hole in the middle to create this I'm
dubious that it's done by hand and so
dovetails are actually much more
impressive than this but it is very
handsome
at Martyn w17 asks what's the best way
to dry a fresh oak slab with minimum
warp I seem to have no success and cups
a lot and with spacers and wait again
consider your grammar give your tweets a
reread before you hit Send just you know
it helps us all comprehend our
communications better drawing wood is
always a conundrum it depends on the
climate where you are I do my best to
seal the end grain - to slow down the
evaporation of the water through the
ends of the end grain you use a lot of
spacers and wait that's all I know how
to do if it's still cupping maybe create
a kiln of your own or find a friend with
a kiln in the neighborhood and try to
speed up the drying time a little bit
that usually can help it cure before the
cupping can kick in otherwise you can
cut them a little fat and then plane
them down
to level once they've cupped a bit but
that potato chip effect is definitely a
tough row to hoe good luck this has been
woods support with Nick Offerman I'm not
a master of the craft but I have read
some books I hope it's been of some
assistance measure twice cut once